[Applause]  15 seconds to go  pacers trying to win let's be patient  let's be patient  sabonis mcdermott let it go brogden for  three  got it malcolm  and the pacers lead by two that's what  i'm saying be patient  you just gotta be patient you get to  look  that brogden is a guy that's been  shooting the ball extremely well wants  the pressure to carry a team  get with a look smart pass  and i mean he just drilled it he stepped  right into it  anticipating that pass to himself  from mcdermott and just knocks it down  to give the pacers a two-point lead  with under three seconds to play second  three of the night for brogdon there may  only be a thousand people in the  building